hello everybody markiplier here and
welcome back to CP containment breach I
just recorded drunk minecraft I'm still
a little drunk and I realized that I had
to record something for tomorrow cuz I
sell to wait on Bob a way to give me
their webcam so we're gonna go and we're
gonna do stuff and we're gonna win I
don't know how this is gonna be I never
played a horror game slightly drunk
before but here we go
woohoo I remember this wait a minute
it seems awfully bright in here
oh yeah
Oh Yahoo
I hate this blade Oh No why I remember
this save is a bad save he's after me I
didn't realize it he was behind me not
old I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm dead I'm
beyond dead I'm gettin dead i'm i'm
altra mega you forget I'm dead
yes good it's good
huh
Oh
that's not right wait what did I just
pick up Oh burn down there okay I
remember this who I'm gonna pick another
name sell my bucket of names here for my
giveaway I dunno what I'm gonna do with
it but I can't bring myself to throw it
away
hi the lucky winner graceful Aurora you
get a code that I'm probably never gonna
get a chance to use bagger your name oh
I need to go don't I
bad things are gonna happen why is it
slow so much brighter it does it seem oh
wow oh I see now I can actually I I can
actually see things this is so weird
I don't know what changed I mean maybe
it's cuz I got a new graphics card in
he's after me he's out my buddy all
right
oh oh no you do go I don't know I should
save doubt by Bennett yes looks good
I saw what did I make the right choice
anointed troll oh not again
I'll cut on here take me too smart for
you huh
great took me I'm sorry
you see behind me
let's just see ah
excuse me oh that's a dead end if I ever
saw one the same again I can't see you
oh I can see you too huh what huh Monaco
drop me whoa watch the up balls I fell
to a halt I died I fell but something
happened
sorry sure what yeah this place is so
right away I can see way no this is the
same when I went up Oh what you gonna do
we gonna do nothing
what
you or your hair smells so nice oh thank
you thank you
whoa I'm back I made it I made it out of
the baggage man I can't believe it I
made it I lived it I survived
I've never survived the pocket dimension
before oh no please refer to all SCP
love love will items by their face a
radical Larry I got it I got I don't
need that I can go away oh man I'm away
I'm away from the people oh my what
what's up I do like it that it's a bit
brighter even you guys can see more and
that's that's what's important now going
the right way I've been here before this
this has been explore these doors are
open ah
OOP Oh poopie Oh poopie poopie I saw
that where did he go eyes in the corner
a I could deal with them in the corner
huh I didn't press a button you're in
the corner oh I didn't
got the coin now haha I do not like that
guy I do not like him at all
whoa whoa oh oh who the restaurant I've
been in here
wait a minute I've been in here it was
the butt monster the bot monster was in
there it was a buck monster that was
gonna eat my foot I've been here before
what's in here I've been in there haha
not fair man I think I just saved there
oh why did I say there no oh my save oh
my good say oh I hate it we think
Oh No
art is so good ah poop-poop
someone's told me that there is an end
of the game you can is-8 the facility ah
excuse me
I'm the full-on douche master I do like
that I can actually see it is I didn't
even
ah I'm bad it was drunk
mm come on save few batteries oh my gosh
where is eight where is up fudge ha ha
look at that wall so great at everything
I do
oh are we gonna get a ha ha ha
level one nothing wonders do anything I
could conquer this I really really I
measured it before but I really like
that is brighter I can actually see you
doing that last vicious suspicious err
I'll go this way cuz if there's anything
that I know you always go down the more
suspicious pathway
oh nothing happened why are these doors
already open is another office funky
couldn't connect a map database ah this
is the thing I wedded that I couldn't
get out of ah this is perpetual darkness
I should have gone in here so now I
gotta work upon one I didn't save in
there did I did I oh I did didn't it so
stupid oh thank you I don't know what
that is all about but it's just bad just
darkness and once you cross that
threshold you can never return
watch are you fall eyes a bug that's
what happens
okay all right okay I got this I got
this project group an error with the
randomly generation of the map
under the bed here
oh come on give me the ax let's go who's
gonna be the lucky winner ah David
Campbell congratulations you get the
access code written on the back of your
name too far seven one I am curious if
you guys wanted me to do another
giveaway promotion there's a couple of
good games that came out recently I
could I could like and whenever there's
a Steam sale I'm inclined to like buy
ten of a game it just give away thinking
I love you guys so much and that's not
just drunk me saying I love you guys I
really do I loved you should be this now
when you are not paying into you're not
paying into tonight I'm going to bite
your Achilles
ah dude dude come on come on
Oh get away from now that's a bad way to
go
on all the time
ah balls all right ah I'm all out of
time
Oh God
I've even enjoyed this just a little bit
pride on at all Friday oh good uh
playing game Corgi la drunken all right
excuse me sorry anyway I'm a lot of time
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotations for more stuff
that I've done all the Let's Plays that
I've done oh good let me know that thing
that I asked about you guys about the
giveaway if you'd like another giveaway
also if you'd like another FAQ cuz I'm
like that if you have questions for me
you know right I'm somewhere I'm not
sure if comments would be a bad play but
if you have question for me I kind of
want to do another epic fu FAQ video and
I like I like talking so let me know in
the comments below and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye bye